I make mistakes every day life's about
alternatives if you don't believe in me
as a leader go work somewhere else
[Music]
you
[Music]
what's up everybody
Thursday morning I'm pretty a pretty
solid day ahead gotta put your internal
meetings bunch of interviews and then
I've got the keynote today's the first
day we're doing the four DS the daily
digital deep dive that some of you are
aware of which is kind of a sapos
disney-like product we've created that
vaynermedia where they go through a
10-hour day 12 people 13 people and
really get to know each other really get
to know all the disciplines that make
modern marketing work so I'm excited
about that and the first five or 10
towards I'm gonna do the keynote so I'm
excited for that
I'll go do that today and then get to
see David Levy president of a turn
relator client friend genius and then
big team dinner with a small group of
vaynermedia employees I'm just putting
together different groups and jamming
the peeps so staying in the trenches Co
life baby CEO life
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yo it up Instagram just got out of
meeting with a fortune 50 CFO tops real
big fans talking to Matt for meetings
today
big day today first day of the forties
daily digital deep dive people come to
Boehner spend the day
and if you learn
what up what up what up I've now come to
the realization that everybody should
have an opinion on me when it's all said
and done yeah which is cool
and I'm excited about and I just want
the people that were closest to me to
have the best opinion because they know
the truth today so far I know you guys
have been excused guys I'm sure of it
amazing how have you been step to me
that's the question I think the thing
that you need to understand and this
becomes very uh rewarding which is
you're young enough that like you want
to do it for two years and if it doesn't
work out shoot my forced shoots into
this situation of ultimately going to be
running this I could be right I could be
wrong I'm intuitive I take on that
responsibility as a leader I also knew
that means he could have came back a day
later like I don't want to do that can
you help me get a different job and he
could no because he knows me and those
that would be the case I think up right
we can find out he knows the company
knows I killed project management I
brought it back like ah like we spend so
much time overthinking instead of doing
do it then no then decide yeah I think
it is cool you know what it is it's
liberating which then allows you to go
fast speed it's all speed like you got
to go fast that's how you get [ __ ] done
that's how you figure stuff out and then
like if you're wrong you say you're
wrong
thanks guys
how great that yeah before you guys
leave I'll try to come in and maybe
we'll do some sort of selfie or whatever
yeah I'll come back awesome sweet I'm
Kara okay and we get for you
yesterday at Fianna would be the one you
my life right I love that to give you
Thank You Conrad the grand Hildy I love
it I have so thank you appreciate very
nice thank you
I know how to do this and I open you
[ __ ] my whole life all right
excited uh-huh
helmut time eighty sixty nine Jeff I
love it man thank you so much applause
unbelievable look for just like luck
thank you for all the amazing stuff you
do for the world
thank you very she ate it thank you so
much very nice
I'll see you guys a little better all
right hi what's up there we go
women so I think it can really help
that's what I want I have that
conversation with you guys know so we'll
have that cool cool responsive better
great to see you again Marcus when you
off crutches I'm getting reevaluate
online saying I almost like one and what
can you basically like as I I'm pretty
I'm so happy he has to do that part
thanks guys okay my pleasure
[Music]
such a project it's officially me
anything I can answer for you because my
inbox is open to you anything like like
I really need it
[Music]
my question for you is really right what
is a well-rounded digital marketer it's
somebody who I think the best is really
of course I do
yeah it's the one that understands that
he or she needs to have the short-term
skills of the moment and the intuition
and tasting ability when I say tasting
the intuitive curiosity around things
like influencer marketing and then as
soon as you buy into it become a
practitioner and as that like it's
always doing that it's always knowing
that the thing that we care about the
most
is a radionics way of being out and to
look at the counter and collateral
damage of its execution and I feel like
you know if you're going to be an artist
it's a time where you just have to you
know embrace the responsibility and
understand the power music is something
so special and be able to do it on this
magnitude where you reach millions of
people it's like why not use that for
good why not tell kids something that
they could connect with and use in their
lives
[Music]